a year ago on the night of September
26th a hundred students from the IOT
Napa rural school came here to the town
of Iguala and 46 of them haven't been
heard from since
thanks to witness reports and a new
independent investigation we now know a
lot more about what happened that night
it was an attack a coordinated operation
involving every level of Mexican
security forces and most likely
organized crime here's how it went down
the students were commandeering buses to
help transport them to Mexico City for a
commemorative March since they don't
have enough money to rent buses
commandeering is something that they
often do convince a bus driver to drive
them around for school activities at the
wall a bus station the students
commandeered two more buses but as they
tried to leave town municipal police
moved in at this intersection police
blocked the students who defended
themselves with rocks there was at this
corner that things got lethal the police
shot student Alou Gutierrez putting him
into a coma his classmates ran around 30
of them were caught and loaded onto
police trucks it was the last time they
would be seen two of the buses managed
to escape but didn't get far one was
stopped in front of iguales Palace of
Justice the students inside haven't been
heard from since students and the other
bus watched from above farther down the
road they too were stopped by police but
they were let go
meanwhile at the first intersection the
police had already cleaned the crime
scene of blood and shell casings it was
around midnight and local journalists
and others had arrived suddenly gunmen
and black fatigues and face masks
approached the small crowd and opened
fire to Yeo chiapas students lay dead in
the street by the next morning security
forces had killed three students and
three bystanders
but it's what happened to 43 students
who were taken by police that still
remains a mystery
the official story from Mexico's
Attorney General said the police handed
the students to a local drug gang that
killed them and burned their bodies in a
garbage dump in the nearby town of
Cocula
but an independent investigation
revealed serious flaws in that official
story based on their six-month
investigation they found it would have
been scientifically impossible that 43
bodies were burned in Cocula they say
the smoke would have been seen for miles
and that the flames would have started a
forest fire neither of which happened
and one of the five buses the students
commandeered was never reported in the
official investigation the Commission
believes this bus may be linked to the
motive behind the attack Iguala is a
major hub for the heroin trade and drugs
are known to be transported to the US on
commercial buses perhaps the students
commandeered the wrong bus and the order
was given at every level not to let them
leave Iguala
while the mayor and his wife and over a
hundred police and suspects have been
arrested military officers high-ranking
police and the iguales Secretary of
Public Security remained free many are
demanding the investigation be reopened
some are demanding that President
Enrique Pena Nieto stepped down but
everyone is left shaking their heads at
the terror and the lies in every corner
of this dark story